the ending of The Last of Us season 1
came as a shock to the uninitiated but
those in the know were bracing for it
all along when they weren't too busy
keeping their eyes peeled for Easter
eggs and there were plenty for fans to
find spoilers for both The Last of Us
games and show ahead
the finale of season one opened with
Ashley Johnson the voice of Ellie in the
games running into an abandoned
Farmhouse to get away from an infected
runner in both games Johnson brought the
character of Ellie to life in the show
she plays Anna who was revealed to be
Ellie's mother throughout the cold open
in which Anna fights off an infected
mere moments after her water breaks
hearing her talk and grunt to surreal
that is impossible for fans of the games
not to picture the digital version of
Ellie Anna is bitten by the runner who
follows her into the house and Ellie is
born during the struggle the source of
Ellie's immunity is never revealed in
the game though it's implied that there
is something irregular about how
courticeps mutates in her brain which is
why the fireflies must perform a fatal
surgery on her to develop a cure in the
finale we learned that Ali's immunity
likely stems from the fact that she was
still attached to Anna's umbilical cord
when Anna was bitten Ashley Johnson
playing Ellie's mother is pretty perfect
but if that wasn't enough Laura Bailey
who plays Abby in The Last of Us Part 2
plays one of the three Master nurses in
the operating room no score spoilers but
fans of part 2 know Abby's connection to
that operating room and what goes down
in it making Bailey's Cameo a
heartbreaking touch there are several
recognizable motifs themes and objects
in The Last of Us and many of them are
shown in the finale we finally get to
see the pivotal giraffe scene that has
been teased all season long and there is
the same harrowing final story beat when
Ellie says okay to Joel Neo Jackson one
iconic weapon however finally gets a
well-earned backstory early in the
episode at the beginning of the episode
Ellie's pregnant Mother Anna fights off
an infected Runner with a knife a knife
is actually the switchblade that Ellie
has been carrying for years a piece of
information we never learn in the games
in fact Anna only appears in the game
via a letter she left for Ellie over the
course of the two games the one constant
in Ellie's life is her switchblade now
that we know it originally belonged to
her mother it carries even more weight
than the franchise's lore
at the heart of The Last of Us Part 2 is
Ellie's relationship with Dina a girl
her rage who came to Jackson before her
and Joel in the first game Dina doesn't
make any appearances and is never
mentioned but it's quite possible that
we got to see her briefly in episode 6
of the show after arriving in Jackson
Ellie and Joel are given a proper meal
from Tommy and Maria while she's chowing
down Ellie yells at a girl lurking
behind the wooden Post in a dining hall
what
what's wrong with you what about her
manners she was just curious
Miguel looks like Dina on the
interaction parallels a conversation she
has with Ellie in the second game when
they reminisce about Ellie first getting
to Jackson stuffing food in all my
pockets for later like it was gonna run
out
I saw that it hasn't been confirmed yet
whether or not the girl was Dina but
show runner Craig Mason Uber confirmed
it on an episode of the official The
Last of Us podcast I wonder who that
could be theoretically or not we'll find
out one day
while touring Junction in episode 6
Maria takes Ellie and Joel to The
Stables well they get to meet a fold
that goes by a familiar name you wanna
pedo ah what's your name Shimmer Shimmer
fans of the game surely perk their heads
up at that detail as Shimmer as the
horse that Dina and Ellie take when they
go to Seattle in The Last of Us Part Two
when we meet Shimmer in the game she's a
fully grown horse so getting to see her
as a youngling is a sweet touch
early on in episode 7 as Ellie is about
to go to bed during the federal school
flashback there is a quick shot of a
stack of cassette tapes on her desk on
top we see aha's Greatest Hits
compilation beneath that there's an acid
James album both the Easter eggs and
continue to get fleshed out across the
entire episode after Riley takes zelly
into the abandoned Mall Ellie Marvels at
the wonders of a working escalator
what's playing in the background aha's
hit song Take On Me fans of The Last of
Us Part 2 will recognize the
significance of the famous song right
away as in the game Ellie plays an
acoustic rendition of the song to Dina
in the music store in Seattle this song
is an important piece of Dina and
Ellie's relationship and the
showrunner's opted to bridge starting to
Riley and Ellie's relationship too just
like in the Left Behind DLC Ellie and
Riley dance and kissed at the James's I
got you babe that song Choice was likely
always going to find its way into the
episode but singer hinted at early in
the episode is a nice touch
that's Riley and Elliot making their way
into the abandoned Mall in episode 7
Ellie's flashlight starts flickering
uncontrollably Ellie shakes her
flashlight to get it working again much
like the player would in the game
whenever a flashlight starts to go bad
in the game players have to gently shake
their controller to get it working again
showing Kelly fix her faulty flashlight
like this is a clever way to insert a
common gameplay moment Into The
Narrative of the show
in the abandoned Mall there is a shot of
a movie poster for dawn of the Wolf Part
2. in the game Joe reveals that dawn of
the wolf was one of the last movies he
and Sarah watched together dawn of the
wolf is The Last of Us universe's
version of Twilight as Joel says that
it's just another dumb teen movie when
Ellie added the main character gets
gutted at the end when the last reverse
was being developed by Naughty Dog
Twilight was one of the biggest movie
franchises in the world Burton liked
Twilight and its five installments dawn
of the wolf was limited to just two
entries before the world fell apart
on the walls of Ali's Federal room there
are numerous space-themed posters
including one of the moon and the Mortal
Kombat 2 poster an interest hinted at by
Ellie in episode 3 that will fully come
to fruition later in episode 7. there's
a picture of a giraffe in there as well
as a plethora of savage Starlight comic
books one of which Ellie reads before
bed on her bedside table too is Will
Livingston's no pun intended volume 1.
we got to see Ellie reading from Volume
2 earlier in the season and it is
episode 7 where we learned that it was
Riley who gifted her the Beloved second
edition there are also dinosaur drawings
a hints to a quick moment later in the
episode and a memorable scene in The
Last of Us Part 2. when Riley reveals
that she has a gift for Ellie Ellie
quickly begins a rapid fire
interrogation of Riley begging to know
what the gift is at the end of her
rambling she offers a final question
isn't it dinosaur s fans of The Last of
Us Part 2 will remember that during the
first major flashback in the game Joel
takes Ellie to a surprise location for
her birthday Joel won't budge on it even
though Ellie berates him with
never-ending questions the dinosaur and
then to our excitement it is Joel takes
Ellie to the Wyoming Museum of Science
and History which has a large full-scale
statue of a Tyrannosaurus Rex outside
one of the biggest changes in HBO's
adaptation of The Last of Us is the
location where Joel and Ellie meets
Henry and Sam in the game the meeting
takes place in Pittsburgh but in the
show it's changed to Kansas City moving
the location doesn't have a huge impact
on the narrative safe out Pittsburgh's
yellow Bridges were used as a beacon of
direction for Ellie and Joel in the game
however Pittsburgh does not get thrown
to the curb entirely in the show in
episode 8 Ellie and David take shelter
in a rundown Barn David tells Ellie that
he was part of the Pittsburgh quarantine
zone until they fell out of fedra's
control viewers who haven't played the
game won't pick up on the significance
of this but Die Hard fans are the
franchise will be pleased to hear
Pittsburgh get a mention David claiming
that the city fell aligned with events
in the Cannon as Pittsburgh is overrun
with Hunters who ruled the streets in
the game
in The Last of Us Part 2 Ellie tells her
girlfriend Dina that Joel's favorite
movie franchise is a Cheesy fictional
80s action series and she wants to use
it as an olive branch to help ease their
strained relationship what movie you
guys gonna watch let's draw into
uh Curtis and Viper too
later in the game while taking shelter
with Dino and Jesse in a Seattle theater
Ellie notices a Curtis and Viper 4
poster on the wall in one of the back
rooms and makes a comment to herself
that it was one of Joel's favorites in
the show fans will noticed that the DVD
Sarah borrows for Joel on his birthday
in episode 1 is Curtis and Viper 2. a
film that obviously holds importance in
their relationship so what's the plot in
The Last of Us Part 2 Ellie explains
that it's about two former Commandos
that go Rogue to fight bad guys and I
think in Curtis and Viper 2 they go up
against Russian spies or something a
young one Viper he's a trained ninja and
he's a complete badass oh this is the
one with the deleted scenes yeah imagine
about those have to be this Easter egg
makes the impact the franchise has on
Ellie and Joel in the video game much
more dynamic as it emphasizes what Ellie
means to Joel and how she has become a
surrogate daughter to him after Sarah's
death Joel is eventually willing to
share his interests with Ellie interest
that he won't shared with Sarah whose
absence he felt so much that he could
barely talk about her in the original
The Last of Us
when players wake up at Sarah in the
video game they have the option to pick
up a birthday card in her bedroom the
card reads congratulations and features
an illustration of a green cartoon
dinosaur wearing a party hat Sarah says
that she forgot to give the card to her
dad but that worry is soon overshadowed
by the noises and Chaos outside in
episode 1 of the show there was a shot
of Sarah's bedroom and that exact same
birthday card can be briefly seen on her
desk underneath some art supplies the
inclusion of the art supplies in the
scene could mean that Sarah went to the
trouble of hand making her father's card
a neat detail left out of the game much
like in the game the shells of the
birthday card are not lingered on for
very long sadly Sarah forgets to give it
to Joel after giving him his repaired
watch and falling asleep while watching
a movie together another neat detail
from the opening Sarah is wearing a
t-shirt for the fictional band halikin
drops in both the show and the game in
both versions a list of tour stops on
the back include several locations that
will be important to the story down the
road
one of the most infamous scenes in the
original game comes when Tommy Joel and
Sarah are attempting to drive out of
Austin amidst the outbreak on the end of
downtown a Tommy's truck is totaled by
another vehicle as he infected attack
survivors and fires break out across
town which leads to Sarah injuring her
leg in the Escape fans were likely
expecting the very same outcome to
unfold in the first episode of the show
given how pivotal this event is in the
last of us and the fact that the same
mirrors the perspective players
experience in the game instead the
writers change the layouts of the scene
opting the first fake audiences out with
an oncoming truck that just narrowly
misses Tommy's truck the chaosa flips
Tommy's truck and the show does not stem
from another roadbound vehicle instead
of plane crashes in close proximity to
Tommy Joel and Sarah which leads to
debris flying at the truck and causing
it to crash the switcher gave the scene
a fresh feel in an episode that was
largely faithful to the original game
speaking of faithful to the game he has
an easy to miss small detail that fans
of the game likely picked up on when
Joel is forced to kill his infected
neighbor with a wrench in episode 1 he
discards it likely out of the skirts of
what he just had to do with it but in
The Last of Us game series wrenches can
be used as weapons and the player was
forced to discard them all the time
since they only have a limited number of
uses so switching out Joel killing his
neighbor Jimmy for Joel killing Nana the
mother of his neighbor Connie was a
fresh take that also nodded at the
mechanics of the game
the world of the last of us has plunged
into chaos after the cordyceps fungal
outbreak in the game it begins with
infected crops in South America however
the show takes one of the main sources
of the spread Airborne spores and
substitute sound with 10 drills that
grow out of the infected there must be
some explanation for how cordyceps took
over the world in the show I was
thinking we'd make some cookies
is to avoid using flower-based products
at least four different times in episode
one first they finally have run out of
it at breakfast to make eggs instead of
Pancakes later they politely decline
when their neighbors offer them biscuits
the same biscuits the infected neighbor
ate after that Sarah and Connie baked
cookies together but Sarah doesn't take
any because they have raisins in them
finally Joel forgets to pick up his
birthday cake after work beyond that the
creators of the show may have hinted at
all this in The Last of Us podcasts
their crane Mason mentions are careful
viewers of this episode will be rewarded
repeatedly because little bits of
breadcrumbs have been planted that are
going to pay off later in interesting
ways plus it just so happens at the
world's largest flower Mill is in
Jakarta which appears to be at the
center of the outbreak on the show
Jakarta where is that Middle East then
ring a bell it's definitely a country
maybe part of Asia Jakarta isn't a
country the second episode of the series
reveals the first cases of the human
variants of cordyceps took place near a
flower factory in Jakarta an episode
later Joel explains to early that it was
indeed contaminated baking ingredients
that helped the outbreak spread
throughout the world so quickly
I do
but I'm on Atkins
when Eddie awakens at the beginning of
episode 2 a butterfly hovers above her
this is a direct callback to various
scenes in the original game where Ellie
is constantly enamored by the beauty of
the butterflies and fireflies living
outside of the quarantine Zone
butterflies become a symbol of Hope
which mirrors the hope that the
fireflies have an Ellie's resistance to
the cordyceps virus which they think May
hold the key to producing a viable
vaccine
scene any child born after outbreak day
is brought into a world of immense
violence and cruelty when Ellie is
falling in love with nature taking the
time to read comic books or cracking
jokes about the adults it's a reminder
that she's still just a kid trying to
piece together some semblance of fun
amid a hollow and deadly reality on top
of all that before the events of The
Last of Us Part 2 Ellie gets a tattoo of
a moth signifying the changes her
character was starting to develop
compared to the butterfly imagery
um just so it's out there I can't swim
in the original game it's a running joke
and nuisance that Ellie can't swim in
numerous missions Joel is forced to push
Ellie across bodies of water using a
wooden pallet in The Last of Us Part 2
flashbacks show that Joel teaches her to
swim and she actually becomes quite
skilled at it she even gets good enough
to make a joke about her past
shortcomings when the two encounter
astray palettes they're a museum in
Wyoming no look
want to give me a ride
those days are long gone kiddos when
Joel tassan Ellie reached a hotel in
Boston there is a lot of water
separating them in the stairwell they
need to get to Ellie says that she can't
swim because there aren't many pools in
the quarantine Zone annoyed by her Point
Joe shows Ellie that the water only goes
up to his knees Ellie's inability to
swim isn't as much of a plot point in
the show as it was in the game and those
ubiquitous Pilots also never come into
play
in the game as Sheldon Ellie are about
to reach the hospital in Salt Lake city
where the fireflies are stationed they
assemble Upon A group of giraffes in an
open field it's one of the most
beautiful and enchanting parts of the
first game and it gives the players a
break from the never-ending brutality
players can stand at the ledge and watch
the giraffes for as long as they'd like
ounce but
he can't deny the view though in episode
two of the show as Joel tassan Ellie are
traveling across Boston and heading
toward the capital building they stop
and taken the sights from a rooftop you
can't deny their View
fragments of the same composition that
soundtrack The Giraffe encounter in the
game are used to score this scene a
subtle link between the game and the
show in the finale we get a live-action
version of the giraffe scene a touching
moments and a heartbreaking and violent
episode is it everything you hoped for
got its ups and downs
you can't deny that view
[Music]
foreign